break a leg i'm gonna try and keep my
legs intact
eric hey how's it going it's going well
i won
i won my game and i played to london
when i was white i've i
saw the beginning of it but i didn't see
the end of it i'm so proud of you
thanks you're not live yet are you
uh i am live i just went live oh
hi yeah chat say hello to levy hello to
levy's chat too
hope you guys are ready you got a lot of
people who showed up here
and i think they like you more hmm i
think somebody who
who who likes your stream said uh that
they're watching your stream they told
me in my chat they're watching your
stream instead of my stream
you're less arrogant oh
well you're more confident so
there's always two sides to the coin i'm
not so sure i feel as though you're
like extremely confident i feel like
it's just
like you're like just you don't need you
don't have to say anything you just you
know i'm not sure about that
no i've i really don't know but
i mean when you say that you you sound
confident so
maybe that's true but maybe it's not
when i say that about you yeah just when
you talk you you have a very
i guess confident vibe which
i i try and live up to but it's
difficult sometimes
oh it's just your your new york vibe
maybe maybe we just changed the title of
the stream like
two i chatting am complimenting each
other yeah you should change the
category
no more london match oh i'm i'm
streaming this entire event in the just
chatting category by the way i'm trying
to
try to see it oh you're experimenting no
i'm not
i i believed you that's like that's kind
of the thing to do these days
to attract a different audience yes yes
well they're gonna
they're gonna pop up and be like uh wow
who's this guy with the beautiful
beautiful
we should probably do some sort of like
formal
we should do like a formal introduction
right i didn't really prepare
any speech but no i mean
yeah we can we can do something maybe
for the the future youtube people
i usually don't have like any formal i
don't have a hello everyone i don't have
hey guys
but uh hey guys this is eric
uh and i did notice that you like you
just you like cr
like time it very well from when it
happened in the stream
but um yeah basically we had this match
with
chihu and somebody in the comments wrote
you should do this with eric rosen and i
was like
that's a good idea i don't remember your
name but maybe i'll put it in the
youtube thumbnail
and uh maybe it's already made so i
don't know if i can do that so eric you
want to do this he said
yes no i saw that youtube comment too
i i think the like some of the best
ideas ever
are born out of random youtube comments
it's incredible no
because some of them are also pretty
terrible that's true
yeah there's there's a wide variety of
ideas
also i think i kind of coerced you into
the 100 i just copied the thumbnail from
last time but
i think we're wagering 20 subs right
that's the
yes i i believe so there's always like i
i have a match
and some match uh several months ago
where there was like a misunderstanding
and like i paid my competitor afterwards
and then they refunded me because
there's a whole misunderstanding but uh
yes i'll um if you take down my london
i'll give you 20 subs all right
um any any final thoughts before we
have anything just one so one technical
question i know
like people in chat want me to trash
talk but
i'd rather avoid being trashy um so
every game i'll be white so when we
rematched should i just like import the
games i'm black
no i'll i'll send you a challenge and
the challenge
every time will be me playing with black
in a three-time game okay cool
hey let's go all right i think we're
good
london time let's go so i did a little
bit of prep
but not so much
yeah i was expecting expecting c5
he's gonna play this early c takes d4
knight h5 line
oh bishop e7
uh bishop e7 he calls for some
like bishop d3
yeah this is a main idea
this is a solid line for black
and some idea like queen e2 rook d1
um
there's a few ways i can avoid this line
uh later on which i'll address but okay
maybe 95 here
there's a weird idea it takes and bishop
takes h7 i think just wins
it's uh it's nifty it's in my london
course so
i think
so knight f6 or g6 expected not f6
i could castle what else to do
queen c2 or queen b one's the move let's
castle
being extra safe
so the whole the whole point of the line
for black was to get the bishop which he
didn't get
he just moved his knight back and forth
and i got a couple of free tempe with
this
and castling which is nice
and light moves for it's not like the
fourth time
uh so f4 is pretty typical though f4 can
run into c4 queen b6 hitting both pawns
so i do have to be careful
queen h4
i mean there's some queen g4
actually c4 c4 is a typical move here
it probably makes sense because i'm i'm
just ahead in development
and yeah black lost a lot of tempe with
the knights
so i want to open the position uh
queen c2 here looks solid hitting the
pawn
and probably just rook d1 maybe when the
time is right i'll play e4
i feel like this first game this first
game is very important to just get a
rhythm
find some flow
uh can i take that
it looks like a very juicy pawn to take
not sure if it works so
i think i'll start with this a spicy
move
i just want to play h5 and if black
plays h5 then there's some
some possibility of sacking
i should always be aware of like the
alignment as well
uh okay let's take
so the bishop's gonna find a nice
diagonal
oh probably take with queen
i still want to play this open up some
line
wow so ignoring my
my pawn storm
i'm considering bishop e4 let's play h5
yeah now there's like nagging pressure
on the h file
king g7 so alpha zero would play this
move
what do i want to play oh there's a cool
tactical idea
queen f4 idea queen f6 doesn't quite
work though
okay let's play this anyway thanks for
the bits
person appreciate that
i'm gonna try and stay focused so
there's some idea queen f6 takes take so
i mean
i would win a piece like queen f6 king
g8
and unfortunately it doesn't quite work
just kind of sad like bishop b5
it doesn't really work either
i'm realizing my queen is just misplaced
queen wants to be here the bishop wants
to be here okay so i kind of lost a
tempo there
i mean okay the position is very
pleasant but i have to be cognizant of
time
some idea bishop f4 then queen h3 and
then eventually taking
and invading h6 and queen defends g2
as well which is nice
c4 with a c4
explosive um play this move
wow so he just doesn't care about my
attack
okay so i'll play queen h3 now i'm
threatening to actually take in bishop
h6
if rook what is this move g5
g5 seems very self-destructive
but maybe it's playable i can take that
play this in f4
my time
now let's um let's play h6 first and
then bishop g3
i spent a little bit too much time there
i like the position because each this
pawn is weak
play this move threatening bishop e4
oh good move
that's annoying
hmm
my time
it still looks okay though holding on to
things
i want to play rook ee2 he's gonna go on
time as well
because the structure on the king side
is really nice for white
queen h5 is a threat
turning this
but i'm not sure what my plan is maybe
this move
always repeats
no draw
a risky move i'm opening the diagonal
i can defend
uh-oh i blunder
i think i blundered there he didn't
punish me though
he's about to flag i'm about to flag
i just want to meet on each side here we
go
oh look at this meat coming oh it
doesn't quite work
or does it i don't know
where's the mate oh under promotion
tactic
i have all the queen turned on
yes i didn't know what key to hold down
uh-oh
okay so the bishop is going to control
a1
oh wow what is this position
please get forks please
so i want to build a fortress
actually building a very pleasant
structure kind of
not really
this is very stressful but everything's
defended
play this move
how do i crack this
oh he's very low on time
i'm gonna try and torture him just a
little bit
this should be a draw though
oh be careful
oh dear
oh no
are you serious i'm losing this oh
that's so sad
this is so so sad once i can swindle
this is really sad
can i build a fortress with this
probably not
how am i losing this
[Music]
i'm still fighting i have knight in
bishop
he's getting low on time
you take my bishop please
so i want to win the pawn first
ah he's queening
i'm throwing a fork ah
yeah he's gonna win this
this is really sad unless
unless i can fight
wait let's not blunder at night
i have to make him work for it please
play this please please please
oh he's so smart
let's attack the queen
he's struggling kind of the queen is
vulnerable
oh i struggled more ah oh what an insane
game
wow i was so proud of my under night
promotion
aha okay uh what a crazy game
i was such a good position i was nervous
though a little bit
man that was 109 moves
okay he was a good sport all right new
game
um london again okay so there's nothing
wrong with opening that previous game
okay now he's playing a dutch
so i'll play the london and get against
the dutch i guess was actually looking
at this earlier
wondering if i can play this
let's try it it's a weird move i
have not ever looked at the specific
position
but um
now we'll see what happens
can i close the chat okay
the chat was still there but okay now
it's closed
okay let's play let's see three
i mean knight c3 is more typical
there's a similar line where white goes
for the setup
an eventual idea like develop the bishop
light comes to e2
and with knight c3 there can be a lot of
build up against the pawn
like even here what does he play against
knight
i guess he has knight d5
um i think it's almost working
i played this move let's play this move
that's a fun opening
this is not your typical london system
like early queen f3 early knight c3
but this is what happens when black
plays a dutch it's just really
really really strange
and the whole idea is to open the
position like box underdeveloped black's
played f5
so i'd like to open the position
generate some threats
i mean if the knight moves i just take
and attack the rook so i think he has to
take
oh so with this i can take
take him 2 for king d1
oh this is getting really crazy
but we're essentially trading rooks and
the knight's going to get trapped
so let's do it so the idea is after it
takes king d2
takes takes black can take back with
check
but then king c1
um
i guess black would be up a pawn but the
knight would be just stuck
and simple idea king b1 king takes a1
okay now this is it's an interesting
move
and bishop b5
it should be five probably king of seven
what is this position
okay so at least i free up the f1 square
so if king f7 i can consider
taking knight c2
king f1 takes
and probably knight f3 in the end
or even queen a7 in the end
looks okay
the nice thing is d3 and d1 are
controlled so the queen can't really
infiltrate
knight f3 looks attractive king can hide
on d8
or on g8
maybe i'll start with knight f3
and then this the a7 pawn will be
hanging
whenever i want to take it
bishop d6 i can play knight g5 man these
games are crazy so far
i really have to conserve my time this
game
so knight g5 oh what is this move
i mean knight e5 looks really attractive
also bishop c4
maybe bishop c4
there's a simple idea knight g5 check
going after the pawn
i'm realizing my queen is kind of out of
play okay let's go for this
if i take
like we have three
it's a good move
and allowing g5 yeah something went
wrong
but the knight's still kind of stuck
try this knight f4
starting this yeah i think he missed his
chance for g5
let's defend g5 still possible though
another crazy position
my queen the whole life time oh oh man
i got so long on time no oh man
i think the position is dangerous um
i got way too relaxed there i was
calling bishop c6 i just had to move
okay not a great start i'm liking the
positions i'm getting
i just have to move a lot quicker
he's definitely playing more confidently
than me
man
i was only 21 moves compared to the
previous game
so i guess i'll wait maybe
can you send me a challenge now you see
i don't know if i updated my settings
correctly
friends i think he's a friend is he a
friend
oh he's not a friend oh okay
me adam is a friend
add friend okay oh another name okay
let's do this let's come back i'm down
zero to two
that's the worst start possible i'm
gonna manage my time
so he's mixing up the responses which is
nice if he plays b6 here i play queen f3
and this is a line if knight c6 i play
knight c3
there's a trap d5 knight b5
if a6 i played d5
so yeah he's definitely not prepared
here so i checked his games i don't
think he's ever had this position
uh that's the best move the the usual
move here is bishop
b4 because i still want to play
d5 and again d5 knight b5
so some nice opening traps
the main line is bishop b4 bishop d or
no not bishop d2
bishop b4 bishop d3 knight d5 and then
bishop d2
um yeah which i think we're going into
i think the engine checked this a while
ago the engine gives like a very small
plus to white
but nothing too too special
vaguely remember just c4 and play chess
oh can i play c4 here though
well okay d5 kind of blocks in the
bishop so i think i'll play some just
central strategy
and leave the pawns as is
because it's hard for the bishop to
actually like get influenced in the game
i probably don't want to play c4 unless
i do
c4 is actually interesting here
um also can i just greek gift
greek looks really attractive
greek gift king g6 queen d3
f5
you can also include h4 in that line
i can't resist too much fun
it might be dubious because this bishop
is defending e6 and that's relevant in
some lines
but again just too much fun
so the question do i want to play h4 or
queen d3 or queen g4
maybe each were first i can actually try
and win
let's see how to do this
let's play h4 first threatening h5
provoking rook
h8 and then queen d3 and then i take on
e6
and f5 should be weak so the line is
this this
this this
so here here takes takes king has to
move away from defending
f1 and i assume there should be
at least some compensation except i
completely missed h4 is hanging
so queen h queen is a
huge annoyance i play g4
i play f42
he's low on time i want to keep the
pressure
f4 might be the best approach
just from a practical standpoint i'll
play f4
if rook h4 then i play this fighting
queen g3
and whenever he takes when i win a bunch
of pawns
i'm also reinforcing the knight and
preparing queen g3
actually queen g3 here is really
interesting
queen g3 queen h8 knight h7 beautiful
move
and another idea is rook here and i have
queen h3
and queen f7 or queen h7 is a monster
threat
i guess he has queen g8
queen g8 we trade
actually not sure
okay i have a plan let's start with oh
wait no no no
wait not queen g3 queen h3 um
what am i saying queen g3 first rook g4
queen h3
i was about to play queen h3 there
initially that would've been really bad
okay so it's it's very concrete rook
here queen here
here and then
there's actually a couple ideas i have
king f2 rug hm1
oh so here's where i thought i had just
knight h7
that's probably good for him though
i can take on e6 oh i have this move too
wait this is simple
or no it's not because he has rook g4
oh rook g4 is happening everywhere
oh
oh this backfired okay let's play king
f2
i completely forgotten h7 rook g4
uh it's it's still very complicated
because rook h1 is coming his king's
still on g6
queen h4 is a move
i guess king e2 not what i want though
you play g3 maybe licking e2
oh oh this is really bad
my knight's hanging play knight h3
there should be a6 as a move
please flag
for this move
his rook is getting trapped almost
kind of
okay rook is trapped you can okay let's
do this
i've got to go for g4
okay let's expand
this is not good gave away the d5 square
oh dear
i'm gonna need a miracle here
oh this is really really bad i wonder if
the greek gift just didn't work
it was probably just a wrong practical
decision okay but there's still some
slither of hope
it's getting weird
what's going on
oh he's queening
check
check no he's actually queening
oh that's so sad maybe i can queen i got
me
ah man these games are so insane i'm
down
zero to three oh he's playing well
he's handling the complicated positions
well so maybe i should avoid
chaos
because i'm i'm getting like the opening
is going very well for me
i think every game so far um
what okay i'll play the london
but this calls so this calls for uh a
joe bava london
so slightly different
yeah normally i would play e4 but i
guess i'm kind of obliged
to play bishop f4 i'll play queen
i guess queen d2 here prepare the early
bishop h6
c6 is playable i'm playing f3
okay i think he promised me before the
match that he wouldn't beat me 8-0
i promised him the same thing
i guess now i've guaranteed my promise
complete e4 i don't care about double
pawns
it only helps strengthen the center
there might be some weird idea knight h2
and then
f3
would probably bishop d3 here
or no does that blunder a pawn
it's interesting i'll play bishop d3 if
he takes and i can take on b5
and take six i hit the rook in the end
so
and the idea is to meet b4
b4 with knight e2
also he goes for this
making sure i'm not missing anything oh
he has e5
but e5 um i can probably just move
bishop c4
because if takes takes uh the queen pins
e5 pawn
so it's weird it looks ugly for white
but black's really underdeveloped
and i still have this potential
i have two bishops too
that's a good move he wants to play
knight e5
so i think the plan is to play f4
eventually
especially like f4 will make h5 stronger
because it discourages g5
he wants me to commit to bishop b3
which is actually okay and i hear i have
queen e2
and still preparing f4
and bishop is nice keeps the queen side
safe
we'll start with f4
okay i want to keep the time advantage
wow really give me the dark sword bishop
what is this
f3 i guess it's playable like two
knights are actually
decent fighters especially in blitz but
it just seems like the dark squares are
going to be
exploitable hopefully
i play rook d1
play rook d1 i think the king is safest
in the center
it's weird but
okay trade off these guys maybe you have
to eventually connect the rooks for
parallel game one
now he wants to to play positional i'll
play king f2
still idea of rook a1 a7 is a bit
vulnerable
i queen d4 too it's another idea
i just want to keep the game controlled
just have to avoid these like messy
and tactical lines
challenge attack along the a file
so i can't win a 7 because the bishop's
tied down to defending
that's a good move
play this probably eventually f5
especially if he castles
i'm liking this position
oh what okay it might it might get crazy
but hopefully in my favor because h7 h7
is hanging
okay how to break through
some kind of rook g4 even rook g5
[Music]
you can be safe bishop e3 let's be safe
eventually i want to play rook g5 well
he wants to play queen h2
nifty
oh that's very nifty actually
i might just be able to take
essentially trying to call his bluff
i think it's okay because if he ever
takes on f5
i take with check meanwhile i'm hitting
his queen i'm just king e2
i assume knight g3 doesn't work because
i can take it queen f7 rook h1
it's interesting i have this move
yeah still eyeing f7
also finding this because half pawns
pinned
oh tactics fossil
there we go okay i won the game let's go
oh it feels so good i forgot what it
felt like to win
he tried to resist but he couldn't
escape my
my grip okay that was a nice game i was
more of a
appeared smogger but
it's still fun to play with bishop f4
this early pressure
okay so at least i'm on the scoreboard
it's three to one the score is right
here
um i just have to
to do that what seven more times
okay
trying to have some momentum
london time yet again oh
i looked up this line there's a few
things i can play
um i'll play knight f3 i'll play uh just
a simple setup with queen b3
vision d6 i probably leave my bishop on
f4
so the drawback of black playing this so
early is queen b3 and b7 is undefended
uh yeah so let's go for this
and this is actually a typical structure
in london where white can accept double
f
pawns but have a good good grip over e5
interesting so we simplify a little bit
i probably should have played queen a3
there
i missed opportunity maybe
position's still pleasant though
i think the queen is usually happy on a3
i know it looks a little bit weird but
it pressures this than this
if c4 is bishop c2
debating knight e5 or g3
play g3 because if takes the knight
might want to enter
d4
this is definitely the most positional
game we've had so far
she wants to play
some kind of b5
i don't know if i'm so scared
let's start with rook here because of c4
i can
move the bishop all the way back
and v5 maybe i can take greedy but
interesting
[Music]
okay so this is kind of a decision
moment
to take with pawn or knight
both seem very reasonable
i'm leaning towards pawn because it
restricts the knight
and the c file's not too annoying
also have knight 95 here
or queen b4 let's start with queen b4
times about level
okay that's a queen trade
so i'm mainly looking at takes an f5
let's do it i mean
there's also queen d2
and leader f5
let's actually keep queens on the board
because there's more potential for me to
attack
and this queen's a little bit like in
the way of the knight
the queen g6 might come
but okay these are my two main ideas
me along with this and this
even this is some useful move
hmm i'll start with h4
i'm not scared of the square
i'm trying to evaluate the structure if
we end up training
even take with other pawn
kind of like a french structure
i'm not sure if i'm threatening much
there
bishop b1 okay let's start with this
he can't take his bishop h7
queen b4 interesting so i could take
there's bishop b5 in the end
um it looks pleasant
because i'm going to try and take over
the c file
like probably this right away
it's very positional b4 could be weak my
a pawn could be weak though too
there's knight d3 here
and when i take i defend this pawn
just have to watch over time
knight c4 b3 knight a3
it's actually a little bit annoying
because knight c2 in the end
if i take
my time is low
i'm not actually threatening much here's
rook c2
just preparing to take
and also preparing probably rook c1
okay let's try and simplify time is very
low
it should still be about equal
i just want to be solid so first goal
hmm i wasn't sure what to do
maybe rook g1 f3 it's weird
but i want to kick the night away
type wonder i may have blundered
i'm not sure
it's getting weird again
ah this is not good
so i'm down the pawn
this is really not good because he has a
better king too
okay at least he allowed that
positional chess
i'm actually not sure how that makes
progress here
oh rook d5 good move
ah should have seen that coming too
i'm losing all my pawns oh that's so sad
b5 coming or that
okay i'm going to lose this this game
almost certainly
i'm just trying to find like some
counter play
rook f8 please
okay here's something
g5 good move
very nice move
and there goes all my pawns
yeah let's resign no stalemate traps
i was unfortunate um positional game
i just got low on time
and it was actually deceivingly tricky
with the knight on c4
that'll be one to analyze
but that was a clean game on his part
yeah this was a nice tactic knight takes
f2
okay london again let's go i mean the
opening has not been the the problem
it's more end game and time management
and tactics okay so with this line i i
delay e3
uh with the hopes of playing e4 e4 in
one move
now this is uh this is kind of secret
prep
the idea is not so well known among
london players because most people just
instinctively play e3
too early
so okay let's go for this
and yeah black just uh or white just
builds up a nice center
i probably allow knight c6 here
um how bad is this
oh that was not a good move to allow
probably bishop e2 was better
maybe it's not so bad i will play this
and just allow the trade
i gave away the bishop here that this
bishop is not so impressive
against these pawns
i just have to take it one game at a
time e5 interesting
if i take
taking is interesting but from a
positional standpoint
i'd rather just rather not
let's start with bishop there's a d2
there's an e3 we got hit with knight g4
click b on b4a5
so let's castle
so there's an idea if f5 there's some
knight g5 idea
which of course he prevents
okay now i can play b4
we actually we just have the king's
indian type structure
um honestly it's probably more pleasant
to play for black
but we'll see start with king h1
i'd love to like prepare c5
it's not so easy to do
if he plays f4 then
it becomes a race to defend an attack
and i have six is coming
this looks really ugly but i want to
play this in f4
i'm trying to like provoke him to close
things down which he does
it probably didn't really help me in any
way
man
g4 is actually a really interesting move
here
it looks so counter-intuitive
g4 h5
maybe the timing doesn't work let's play
h3 first
g4 is still an idea the problem is queen
h4 ideas
okay now he allows it
so the whole point i just want to close
everything down
at the kingside close down closes down i
can focus on the queen side
if takes takes it's hard for black to
break through
so this is a very small victory for me
you have h5 then i'm just going to like
turtle up f3
okay we don't go into that
that's interesting takes takes
i think this is okay
i can always throw in rook f8
i don't think i need to though unless
oh just have to calculate rook f2
we have two main knight f3
okay so probably this move
really gotta manage time
good move
idea knight g3 knight f5 he might try h5
and just make things really crazy but
then i win g5
i probably want to play rook g1 knight
g3
with g4 i'm also stopping knight h5
which is nice
okay let's go for this
trying to cement the bishop here
it's crazy
that's a good move
i'm trying to simplify g5 might be weak
in the end
but c7 is week two so we get some end
game i have knight b5 in the very end
i stock queen h5
that's a good move let's take
[Music]
have to try this
yeah i'm losing this pawn oh this is
unpleasant
i'm not even winning c7 i'm not even
threatening this because q7 check
which is really sad
let's try and fight
now i'm along queen h3 too
oh this is really brutal
oh dear
the king g4 would run into or king f3
ran into bishop g4 mate
okay still trying
all it takes is one night fork
how this bishop hair is so strong
my knight's getting trapped maybe
but actually probably
yeah there goes my knight
my sad sad night
these positions yeah no this is this is
lost
well played man and it's five to one
i regret yeah so i regret allowing
knight c6 in the opening
um but yeah he got like a very easy
position to play
all right i have to stay mentally strong
dutch maybe oh this
okay let's play so with this line
i can commit to e3
expecting knight f6 f5 is also possible
yeah so i'll just employ with this i'll
just employ a very traditional
[Music]
london setup i think the queen sometimes
likes to
to go to b3 but the bishop will go to d3
there's some idea h3 rook g1 g4
so maybe not like super traditional
i like the fact he's thinking oh
actually i was looking at this
line like right before the match started
he played alejandro ramirez in this line
on chess.com
and you use this idea ramirez just left
the bishop on f4
um i just remember the engine saying to
take
i think i'll go for this idea
interesting so if i take
g4 might be playable here
it's kind of crazy
and 94 is actually kind of annoying
if i take
new rook f1
i'm gonna play rook f1 it looks weird
but i'm just over defending the pawn
on the castle queen sign
and this is what happens when i i show
my cards
i'm in the castle anyway i don't really
mind the pawn storm
even like the plongest a3 i'll play b3
eventually i want to get in this move f3
i'm going to try and keep the time
advantage too so i'm threatening to win
upon
expecting d5
and then maybe maybe knight g1 there
let's go for h3
i want to keep the queen slide closed as
close as possible
always play king b1
oh he wants to play knight b4 which is
kind of annoying to stop but i have this
move
and a3 is loose also this pawn is loose
so i think he's just mislike c4
so queen e7 i can probably take on b6
even
interesting
so if i take
i would like to take
it's not so simple
that was a very resourceful move
so if i take take and d5 comes
i think maybe i can take on a3 probably
not because knight b4
wow that was a really nice move
i have to move though takes takes takes
takes i could sack
actually wait a minute maybe i can do
this let's try this
because the pawns are still forked i
spent all my time there though
i play 91 to start knight d3
that's annoying
oh black's gonna start throwing punches
my b4 queen b2 i'm still alive
kind of i can't find this alexa
you might see two still
or the other night comes to c2
when it comes to c2 would be nice
you're trying to complicate things
especially with my time situation
idea b5
being extra extra safe
i want to play f3
i'm okay trading on b4
there's a d3 king a1
and such a passive game wow really does
that work
i don't know if it works
it might work we might just be trading
though
maybe there's some perpetual
my light should be better here
try and gain some time
oh this could be a long endgame grind
white's definitely better
trying to induce d5
also my b pawn's a pass pawn which i
kind of forgot about
so i just want to roll with the b-pawn
and put a rook on b2 eventually
don't name me
safe move
i can just check in queen or i can just
queen immediately
okay wow what a game so i i survived a
very vicious attack
and then somehow managed to win
okay so two to five
so only okay only have to take it one
game at a time
[Music]
next time i probably won't take on d6 if
we repeat that line
okay this is kopsky's line i was
actually looking at this a little bit
last night
and idea is just to leave the bishop
here
and develop normally
kamsky's been playing this a lot online
been streaming too
what does this move he wants to play
queen c7
the c4 actually looks attractive here
because of queen c7 then i play c5 and i
just get the
bishop get initiative
so b6
yeah now the knight develops a little
bit more actively
there's a typical trap knight d7 that
takes f7
he's not going to fall for it but it's
useful to know
and queen e7 makes sense
so queen a4 actually looks attractive
here because i'm tying down the knight
to defending the pawn i'm also pinning
the pawn
so
that doesn't matter too much
envision d3 looks active it takes i take
with queen
otherwise if i take with a minor piece i
get forked
i guess he wants to play b5
i'm gonna have to allow it
just do this
b5 i take
okay so we go into this
yeah this has some like uh miran slav
resemblance he wants to play c5
eventually
maybe even right now
let's see five maybe i just take life
goes on
i like to move 94 here
this typical idea before blocks
committed to c5
and i pressure the bishop if i get the
bishop to e4
or just like this diagonal then the c
pawn can be weak
and pinned i'm also unleashing the rook
he wants to play knight g4
okay i have to take then i'll probably
think knight e4 queen c3
that's also a move
i don't need to retreat
i can play i play this immediately
actually
yeah i'm okay if we trade i'm also okay
if i win a free bishop
i'm actually threatening to take and win
the pawn two of rook b8
okay so that defends i have queen c2
so i might be winning a pawn
there's not before to worry about
not super simple i'll start with this
so the calculation is h6 takes takes
takes
it takes takes knight b4
oh night before i can just take on b6
it takes on d3
yeah let's just go for this don't want
to waste time
the the ball is in his court too
and i'll just react to whatever he does
so knight a4 that's a move
i was thinking uh b3
b3 knight b4 with d6
knight c5 bishop e1
let's do it
there's also a visual e4 it probably
doesn't work
so let's go for this
wow probably a3
yeah the knights are very strange but
weirdly effective
um what to do maybe g4
a loop for the king
from upper pawn but it's still kind of
complex
i just want my king to join the party
it takes probably gonna have to take
once i leave it there let's actually
leave it there
worst case scenario there's a pawn back
it should still be equal
i'm not sure how he wins the pawn back
that's a useful move
let's bring the king even more
eventually h4 g5
keep the files closed now the bishop
actually has a nice square now
oh he's winning is he winning it the
king takes
it's gonna get weird
if he wins that he's better he's also
flagging almost
and g5 was useful move
yeah okay trying to survive this
[Music]
position
it locks definitely better here
well wait what does that work
with a5
i'll just be safe
ah long knight c4
should still be a draw i have the worst
side of this so
there should still be a draw better be a
draw
g5
check
this is going to be our first draw
probably
okay it's a draw all right
i was it was a hard fought game uh i'm
probably better around here and then
just allowed this
i'm not sure maybe i have something
better
was the time scramble was opening oh
yeah is this 95 line i was happy with
that line
all right uh waiting for next game to
start
yeah that was actually a very pleasant
position from the opening
okay london again i'm not really getting
tired of the
london
and he he's mixing it up every game
uh i'll play the slime i think yeah i
know what to expect now
yeah he's going to take and yeah bishop
so this is the main thing i prepared
g6 and knight d3 key move
g4 is also a move there but knight t3
it's
um i think objectively like white has a
small advantage
so the line here is g3 knight f5 bishop
f4
i'm pretty sure levy had a game against
qiu in a similar line
b6 is interesting
because he wants to play bishop a6
you can just allow it
in knight f3
i'm long not a five though
okay there's a or queen a4 but
that's not good yet
okay he's going for e5 which is
definitely a typical idea
might be playable here i'm not sure
the problem with e5 it weakens d5
okay
so bishop f4
f4 can i count
i'm covering that enough times
a lot of central pressure like most of
my pieces are controlling e5
and his pieces too if you can't play e5
then it's um
oh wait what oh
okay i should probably take on d6 i kind
of miss that
i don't think it's so bad though i'll
take back
if he if he takes my bishop if he keeps
his bishop i keep my bishop
then i'll have the bishop here
so i'll have the bishop here
question is where to move the bishop
bishop
iv
calculating e5 takes takes
rookie 4 queen b3
okay never mind okay a4 is a typical
move
and someday i might want to play a5
another idea is to put the queen on a2
in the event of knight a5
he plays 95 early
i think i'm okay with trading because
you can't play e5
and there's pressure along e file as
knight's restricted by mine knight
might want to play v4 even
h4 also you might play g5 here vision e3
i think queen of three is a nice move to
throw in
i feel like we're both solid probably
we're both happy
okay so we can trade
oh a4
that's interesting
i'm thinking b3 b3 bishop d2
it looks weird but the pawn will be
defended
pondered grinning
you could even play rook e2 first
we both have kind of a backwards pawn
yeah objectively this should be close to
equal but it's going to be a fight
eventually things will probably get
crazy
um let's start with h3
maybe f4 f4 just allows this
the tree was probably not a good move
now let's go a little bit crazy
idea a5 eventually
some idea of taking doesn't quite work
though
and 96 could be coming
i'm just trying to poke some hole like
now now this is slightly weak
i think h4 is called for
if 94 i might even play f3
interesting play f3 right away
i'm trying to take him in the pond
okay let's move back
i'm trying to fight for something more
and just to draw
eventually g4 maybe timing has to be
precise though
that's annoying
so e6 is pressured
okay let's go there we go free rook is
always nice
yeah the position was all about patience
i'll put the bishop on f2 and go for g4
and just go for this
let's always have to be careful
okay okay
it takes a lot of work to win a game
i guess that's the nature of chess
that's a nice game though i think
uh very very positional like
kind of uh nothing settled down after
the opening
hey he played the different mover that
game
yeah he might just take and play uh a
caro khan
yeah um
i know he's capable of playing this
so here and here are the two main moves
oh g6 yeah i saw he plays this
um i think in general
white just plays solidly and
the bishop has a hard time developing
unless it develops to f5 but it's a
little bit awkward with the g
pawn
[Music]
actually i looked at this line briefly
before the match
okay so the bishop develops i'm not
quite sure what it does
you might want to play knight e4
i'm just going to hold my ground
like maybe at the right moment i can go
for
[Music]
let's say with queen i can go for like
g4
or knight h4 and question the bishop
there's some idea of bishop h6 but the
bishop on g7 is
just undermined by the pawns ooh
f6 so in general c4 is the
response to f6 a c4 allows bishop e4
maybe just bishop f1 even bishop d3
i'll play bishop d3 i just want to stop
e5
and make f6 look like a bad move
so i unleash the rook i have
wait can you still play that can you
play e5
i don't think it works
there's some weird stuff on that file
the e5 takes takes takes oh rook f3
oh oh
oh this is kind of troublesome
wow i'm in trouble
okay so i have to go for this i have to
go for this bishop g5 line
at least i win d5
was not great to allow
i'm expecting rook f3
and it's actually it's rook and pawn for
two miners if we go into this line
lions takes takes takes takes king h
actually maybe there's maybe it's not so
bad because the knight and bishop are
actually really
misplaced
and the rook's out of play too
but in general knight and bishop are
preferable
he's probably considering queen d7 here
but then i
at least have a move to to escape e4
actually queen okay so he goes through
this
wait a minute can i play queen d queen
d2 doesn't work or i got six
even bishop f6 okay let's take
we should rookie could be coming
thinking queen f7
or just rookie two probably just for he
too
useful move f2 will be safe or safer
f4 could be interesting
my form might help lag more than helps
me though
let's keep piling up
thinking queen b5
so keeping pressure on b7 and e5
some idea of f4
[Music]
maybe now queen c4
play a42 or h4
this only moves to consider i'll start
with a4
i'm just trying to make like a small
improvement
i keep my time steady as well
maybe before here
oh he wants to do tricky things
okay let's move the queen away i think
he was threatening this
that was very tricky
okay
try this
the king should be on each one so when i
play f4 there's no danger
um
okay so attacking the pawn
i'm preparing f4 almost kind of
f4
let's go for it not super confident in
this but we'll see
oh good move
d2 rook e2
to rely on some tricks
wait what oh good move
try this ah that's not working
ah try this
dough mine rook i got forked
that was a really weird position
bishop f6 was useful because it defended
the rook and threatened my rook
i didn't quite have time maybe i should
have went for this idea
yeah i wasn't quite in time to play e6
it's unfortunate but that's life okay
still in the match
i can't so i can't lose another game at
three and a half to six and a half
i really don't want to gift him 20 subs
so i'll need to win i basically need to
win four in a row
all right let's try and stay focused
and not yeah this game i just allowed e5
so bishop d3 so i probably should play
bishop b5 here
which actually prevents e5 i was kind of
scared about
bishop e4 so i guess maybe i just
underestimated this move
are we starting another game maybe
i don't know what's going on
um the games have been starting
automatically so
let me check the chat
hmm
or maybe this is just a small break
a moment moment of silence for my
position
yeah so the opening really hasn't been
the problem it's more
it's like every game is determined later
on
um maybe he can challenge me okay oh
there we go
okay
so now the whole match is on the line
let's see what he's up to um
this is a move a lot of beginners play
honestly not a great move
um but playable i guess f6
um
[Music]
i'm wondering if i can make c4 work
the c4 work here c4 takes
usually c4 looks nice
i've never seen i've i don't think i've
seen knight c6 f6
like so soon
wow
i guess this is playable thinking i
could take
oh dear okay i have to calculate
bishop g3
bishop b4 is going to be coming
this is fascinating if it works i think
it's just bishop g3
it's definitely making me think
okay expecting this move that may be
queen a4
i do feel a little bit pressured here
like sensing a little bit of danger
another three i probably butchered the
opening already
and then f3 okay
so pressuring e5 if he takes on d4
i take with knight
this shouldn't be so bad it takes on c4
i take on e5
it'd be more dangerous if like the
knight can come to e4 which i can't
i'm threatening queen h5 in some
variation
so we're going to have a french position
okay i'm fine with trading
a flexible move see what he does against
b7
because b6 is very weakening b6 probably
queen a4
probably still queen a4
calculating castling rook takes b7 it
doesn't quite work though
unfortunately
play bishop e2
um
you can probably castle here
if takes i take with bishop
looking at c5
connect four
oh i blundered though a lot of knight
takes d4
oh that's really bad oh no
knight takes d4 queen takes d4 it
doesn't work
okay i'm still alive
maybe f4
i'm not super pretty
this is actually really ugly because
that four could be coming
i can play for myself
still have to watch out for this tactic
oh yeah knight d4 queen d4
eventually i want to play c4
i can probably build it up
and do your knight f1
uh let's build it up one more move
apply some pressure from all directions
hmm
i like this position
it was a bad decision
but maybe it's okay i can dig with pawn
i've got the c file or windy five
okay
good move
you
oh no
might still be winning this
now this is winning
because that phone is marching
wow okay i don't know what happened that
game i thought i was about to lose
there was some rook g2 idea i managed to
trade things off
crazy game okay life goes on
so just take it one game at a time
one game at a time
maybe deciding what line to play or
maybe he's recovering from the previous
game
um i'll play this line
there's a few few options here
i'm actually curious what he's playing
in this line uh queen c7
so the idea is to take and then just
knight f3
i'm fine with this and then usually the
plan is e4
it's kind of a new way of playing but
it's a fun way of playing
there's also queen a4 queen a4 to
prepare g4 g5
or just queen h4 and then push the pawn
i didn't look at this like right before
the match
but this is a line or like a kind of
type of position i've i've looked at
before and i understand the main ideas
like these are basically the two main
ideas along with the queen swing
and when black commits to h6 and g5 can
be very strong
especially with the rook on the the half
open file
and for the time being e5 is prevented
we might see knight c6 or knight d7 then
e5
i'm realizing e5 actually comes quite
quickly
so queen h4 e5
i have e4 there but then g4 is prevented
so i might want to play e4 right away
yeah which maybe i shouldn't have played
queen a4
i didn't really yeah this didn't work
the way i wanted it to
i guess queen c2 here
it's still playable got this break in
i might castle queenside i might also
castle kingside
probably should castle king signing
let's knock b3
knight p3 is a move
arguing the knight is a bit misplaced
we need two here
or even i can't castle yet
on the castle king side we'll keep it
positional
try and maintain my time advantage
so rook c a queen e2
i guess i want to take when i get the
chance maybe i should have taken
probably should have taken right away
but i'm okay if black takes me
it takes takes looks okay
could very well get some iqp position
which would be very pleasant
it's interesting am i winning a pawn
bishop e4
vision before f5
oh but i can
he's so tricky maybe queen
queen e2
so if he takes takes bishop b5 i have c4
i'm
attacking the knight defending
everything
now he's going to have some initiative
like bishop c6 rook d8
a485
the white's clearly better here
okay probably this move
just want to trade queens and get a
knight to d4
or just knight on d4 regardless
probably doesn't make sense to take that
maybe it does
it's queen e4
play queen f4 and then knight d4 coming
um
probably rookie one of d1
that's a move
don't really want to play f4
it's actually a really annoying move
this is not the move i wanted to play
but all i want is nylon on d4
okay
it's always time is very low
i should have taken
here we go
is there mate not quite seeing nate
the kings in the meeting not that's
mates
okay that was nice
yeah i felt i felt in control most of
that game
but it was yeah i was kind of intense
and crazy
and then time got low okay so oh it's
getting closer
i i just want to focus on playing good
moves and not worry too much about the
score
okay london time yet again
what okay i'll play this um
i'll play c4
see what he's up to
yeah this is actually an interesting
variation
i'm assuming we're all oh we're not
going to transpose
um
so one purpose of knight fd2 is that
okay i'm preserving knight c3 i'm also
enabling f3
and now square is under control
though e5 could be coming
okay let's find knight c3
e5 is very likely coming
maybe casting queen side
it looks risky but why not
maybe like bishop z5 and yeah and go for
e4
maybe just e3 you even play bishop h4
here
actually let's yeah let's take i didn't
want the my other knight coming into f6
yeah gonna try and play as controlled as
possible
always play king b1 probably bishop d3
coming next
eventually they'll try and poke and prod
now g4 can be slightly difficult to get
in
unleash the queen to help defend the
pawn so i'm
kind of preparing e4 e4 is probably no
good because he
responds eventually with e5
interesting
92
i'll play 92 and also play queen f2
you can allow that
not entirely sure how to respond to this
i play
play knight g3
maybe that's the way to go just pressure
the pawn
if f4 i take and i get the e4 square
i'm leaving some tension
i might want to play f4 myself actually
a positional move
and f5 is currently attacked
queen f2
[Music]
we have to kind of runs into f4
but let's yeah let's start with this
giving him some options
because f4 is risky because g6 is on
loose
i might just want to build up like rook
t2 put another rook in the center
i'm still keeping f4 in mind
okay never mind
i could take i could take either way
me keep the knight restricted
now i'm not quite threatening knight f5
but it's a tactic to keep in mind
so rookie 1 is interesting
just trying to fight for the e-file i
just want to double up
this queen is so close to being trapped
92
it doesn't quite work
okay let's let's go for this
we could end up trading off everything
not so ideal
my nice very misplaced
interesting
well that's a good move
i have to try this
simplify
you
i'm probably worse here black's just
more active
pawns are fixed on light squares
probably a draw would be a good result
making d4 doesn't scare me
um
that force scares me don't do it
um
i'm not looking good
try and trade off everything
am i drawing this i think i'm drawing
this
he's going to be annoying though
nights in time
check
now this is a draw okay barely barely
survive this
okay survived it so it's it's six to
seven
so now he basically has drugs he draws
he wins the match
if i win i don't know what happens
if i win we play one more
wow okay
man and it's getting close
mmm this line again
i'll play f3 this time
and bishop d7 is a good move
i should have looked at this closer
beforehand
the c5 is coming
okay let's play a3 so it's actually just
kind of a jobavo london
um this isn't so bad
queen d2
oh maybe i should have i should have
included knight
knight b5
okay let's go for g4 so i'm basically
going for this setup
this is not what i'm used to playing
um but it looks playable bishop's on d7
arguably a little bit passive
and light always has a square here you
can re-wrap to f2
in the future
debating whether to play h4 maybe just
king h1 first
clicking each one first and then leader
h4
so i want to play rook d1
bishop e5 is actually interesting
actually knight d1 also maybe i'll play
my d1
simple idea c3 reroute
the curtain setup is a little bit
awkward he could hit me with eventually
knight c4
oh my pawns hanging
but do i care
i kind of care i'll play h5
yeah e5 might be coming
e5 bishop e3 even takes in d5 is a bit
loose
bishop's defended
bishop even more defended oh
i have fort okay
must win situation two
i thought c4 i just didn't see b3
blind spot
it's still okay for a must-win situation
because the rooks are
a bit out of play
just a question how i deal with how to
actually create an
attack knight g3
play rookie one first
now i want to keep as much tension as
possible
h5
so the idea is to play f4
that's my idea
it's really difficult to play this down
material and to play for a win
i'm trying though
next e5
good move
let's go for this
let's take this way
so bishop d3
really
i thought this just wins the pawn that
gives black more targets
roxc8 or that
i'm going to need a miracle
nine of five is a hope
we're running out of hope though
just talking enough too
okay there's one trick 27 takes takes
not a five
it's also h6 which is a major idea
the pawn is hanging he didn't take it
okay
no wait
no ah
oh that's so sad
this should be a draw though
um wait what happens if he flags no i
take a draw
oh good game nice match that was close
man this final end game
we kind of both choked like we both gave
each other so many chances
it should be winning here i assume so i
calculated uh here
takes takes e7 bishop b5
[Music]
and
i'm actually not sure there might be
some way to win i'm not sure though
um that was a good match though let me
let me say hi to chat oh hi chat chad is
still here
okay let me i'll turn back on
okay a few things to do first of all
congratulations to levy
that was very hard fought um
i'm happy that it wasn't eight zero
i was like as close as it probably could
have been
is coming down to the end
and yeah i probably should have lost
this game a lot more easily
oh thank you down dd
yeah alert box is now back on
um i thought i'd should change the sound
from alert box but maybe not
i think so the london's probably still a
very much a live opening
um because all the games this match were
not determined in the opening
yeah especially especially this game
so i'm actually really curious in this
line
sometimes when black has a g pawn it can
still be winning
hello hey eric hey nice match
that was that was toxic trivia
yeah uh one sec i'm just i'm pulling you
up okay
oh dude i feel like i just like had the
longest blood draw of my life
me too yeah well at least in the
beginning i felt like
i was just dying game after game after
game
and then somehow i don't know you
you revitalized me and then then this
finish was
was a bit crazy it was uh it was it was
the game where i hung the rook
queen a6 b5 i think that was oh yeah
that was because i felt like i was i was
pressuring and then that's right
yeah yeah momentum shifted for sure
we had some plans to analyze positions i
don't
that's still the plan yeah like this
this was like exhausting
yeah i'm completely okay letting
letting people in the future youtube
comments uh
spit out their analysis and um
i mean there's so many moments but i
think overall the like
the all the games were determined much
later
beyond the opening yes
yes uh like people in my chat are like
is this the end of the london system
well considering i came literally to the
borderline of losing this match
probably not also i thought i mixed it
up
i think i played a different setup yeah
every game
which was impressive i was running out
of options like some had little f5 moves
some had g6 but
um yeah even early on like i wasn't
getting
dominant positions from the opening or
anything like that i mean it was just
games
and then that was it so yeah i mean i
think
like all the openings were and they just
led to fights
i don't know i'll probably go back like
this is probably a very good
uh i guess learning experience to delve
into theory
a bit more deeply and and to find
like i was trying to play some tricky
ideas um
that were maybe a bit more offbeat
and and some lines i actually prepared
beforehand with uh
with engine but not not too nothing too
specific
oh yeah i was very perplexed you had a
very early night c3 and i had to play
bishop before then you agree gifted me
and somehow i didn't lose
yeah i actually don't know if the like
if that was objectively the best option
it was wild though it's like one thing
to analyze
yeah when we have more energy yeah i
like as a lot of stuff is happening in
the background in my apartment as well
like i
was like supposed to end well and it
wasn't supposed to end there was a very
legitimate chance this could have gone
three hours and i
i was just really hoping that it
wouldn't
but it did and now we're here
um yeah i'll probably just hang out with
my child are you planning to stream more
so no i'm i'm i'm ending things i'll
have to
uh to wipe away my tears and then give
you some subs
so yeah i can't give you on this um
i have to get you from my laptop so i'll
probably end my stream
and then then share some love so
i guess and and that way people in my
chat will go to your stream
and they'll have a chance of getting a
sub gift
oh so that's pretty cool uh yeah i was
uh i was battling a few
weird chatters uh who were trying to go
back and forth and spread intel that was
my
ooh but i had my chat completely turned
off
oh wow except at the very beginning i i
couldn't figure out how to turn it off
but
eventually i did and then and tried to
stay focused
but yeah i uh
i i have it open just in case someone
writes something bad oh sure
yeah i have to mod it so i know what you
mean um
but yeah this was uh this was great and
uh if we if we ever wanna
have a rematch oh yeah after
after i recover i'll someday i'll get
revenge
one way or another i could play london
you could play black
that could be interesting yeah like that
then we'll see if it's uh
the fault of the opening or the fault of
the player